jason sudeikis we caught up with Jason a
couple of days ago and he's got a new
show it's called tournament of laughs
it's hosted by Jason it airs Sundays at
10:00 Eastern on TBS and I started the
interview I asked him does he get to
choose the names of his characters in a
movie like principal brown and
book-smart
or Kurt Buckman in Horrible Bosses
[ __ ] no although I did I have fun
named Dave Bachman so that I think maybe
I just sort of like honored that and
then principal brown his full name is
Jordan Brown who is a good friend of
Olivia nice so like there's always some
you know if they let you yeah I'll
always try I use a lot of old you know
great school friends and whatnot that
was a big point of pride on my ass
nowadays was to you know never have my
name referred to but playing a doctor
and playing like dr. Tim grass or who
was you know one of my friends in high
school I just it just appears on a door
on a name plate and you know it really
lights light to my facebook page up for
you know a good three days but Fred in
haul pants did you not yet that was
already there that was you know I didn't
have any you know they the the deep and
wide Hollywood juice that I have now I'm
just along for the ride and I'm
wondering how often you had guys come up
and say hey I tried the Hall Pass thing
like to get people in real life who who
say that they've tried to get the Hall
Pass or did the hall pass or inspired by
Hall Pass it comes up it will be like
guys be like hey man I love Hall Pass I
watched it in a hotel when I was you
know away from home you know for a work
trip like it implies their their wife or
their partner would not let them watch
it on the home television like no honey
we're not gonna watch Hall Pass even
though you know having having a you know
watch movie a couple times like you know
we we are the the female side of the
hall pass as well but but yeah
definitely
I've never heard anybody actually take
take it up on I've heard the term
bandage around like hey you know like
you know so
so is my Hall Pass oh my god okay look
great yeah you know the sort of like
whoever that might be you know I have to
be but does this come up with your wife
where you know you know she'll
eventually say you guys really think
that way or talk about that stuff it's
all make-believe tough that's the beauty
of having someone who's also in the
business when you're an actor it's such
a weird you know saying it to pretend to
fall in love with people and you know
all that kind of stuff and so she knows
he knows it's all it's all make-believe
it's all wish fulfillment the the show
is Tournament of laughs and it airs
Sundays at 10:00 Eastern on TBS how much
of a stand-up comedian are you or did
you want to be I never did it I've done
stand-up maybe twice you know no three
times the first first couple times I
auditioned for SNL was in a stand-up
menu before they have you do the screen
test which happens on what we call home
base that's like where the host does the
monologue and then the one other time I
did it was like a corporate gig hired by
a business back home in Kansas City and
I did it where they're like hey no do 30
minutes you're you're opening for the
Little River Band this is true and and
and I thought oh I'll just you tell like
you know three or four stories like from
my earliest Rennell days and then maybe
take questions and you know kind of go
The Carol Burnett Show route and be like
oh maybe I can you know and it was so
scary it's so scary I prefer to have you
know someone on you know in the foxhole
with me of when a sketch is dying or you
know an improvised scene is dying and
but you know I'm a team sport guy and so
like stand-up you know all respect
because those guys and gals that do it
on a daily you know nightly basis but
for me it's too scary I want someone in
the ship with me when we're going down
to look at each other and be like oh
here we go this is not flying because
that time I did it I immediately called
a buddy who worked for that company and
text them afterwards going do I guess I
just need for a large you know chunk of
change from a local you know local boy
does good and then clearly not that good
it was it was it was it was intimidating
to say the least and just that sort of
having no one else to blame it on
besides you know just yourself and your
apathy or your work ethic it is too much
for me to handle now I can't do it but
here you are hosting this and explain
the premise of a tournament of laughs
well I basically just you know it was
you know pitched a while back by the
producers as a way to you know make up
for the March Madness tournament or you
know so double A's game um you know
cancelled this year and yeah it's
basically stand-ups people who primarily
you know from stand-up with some you
know the different folks do you like
Michael Rapaport and triumph the insult
comic dog you know having fun making
home videos and then yeah let let my
audience at home you know decide who
moves on and I'm basically putting you
know doing year old yeah you know I kind
of like the host of SportsCenter you
know just doing a little commentary
before and afterwards and just kind of
explain it when you know a number eight
feet as upset and number two seat or
what have you and yeah it's it's you
know today we film it based on tonight
or last night
you know results so it's about as close
to the turnaround that we used to have
which is which is one because I'll do
like that it you know a table read here
in an hour and or so and the quality
knows good tape anyway yeah the
turnaround the turnarounds pretty good
pretty exciting too because it's just
like you know go go go we got it we got
a filmer so they can edit it and have it
ready for next week and and yeah that's
one thing after another he's Jason
Sudeikis the show is tournament of
laughs it airs Sundays at 10:00 Eastern
on TBS when you were in college at Fort
Scott Community College did we ever show
any of your highlights on SportsCenter I
don't think so okay there was a may be
on ESPN for he might have been further
down like in between you know footage of
a father and son playing catch out back
you know it was a highlight I had many
what was the highlight of your college
basketball career that's a good question
probably probably when we played against
Rubin Patterson at Independence
Community College and he had like 50
points on us and I would say 48 more
dunks like that was the highlight
he went to Cincinnati after that didn't
he yeah I mean I mean to play basketball
how much you into the class I mean you
know Bobby Huggins you know Coach with a
different mentality you know maybe the
nineties you know is there and I was
also wondering about Ted lasso yeah now
you did those promos for the the Premier
League with NBC and then all of a sudden
are we gonna do a series on Ted lasso is
this like Brock Meyer Jim Brock Meyer
right no the way which is one of my
father's favorite shows when he when he
heard we were doing the show you I told
the premise he's like hey Brock Meyer
which is you know if I can make my dad
happy that way them all forth but but
yeah that I mean yeah just seven seven
short years later now if you coming to
an apple an apple plus channel near you
but yeah the trailer drops tomorrow
actually uh and yet we film the first
season it comes out August 14th on Apple
plush and it's the same premise as the
first commercial I'm gonna I'm a
small-time college football coach who
gets hired to coach a professional you
know Premier League team a fictional one
IFC Richmond but but yeah we're with ten
episodes that all states in about a
month is the most finished real oh yeah
very much it wasn't in the it wasn't in
the second commercial the second
commercial we didn't have the time to
grow it but we had some of the geniuses
behind the scenes at us and that'll help
help me do that but yeah this for the TV
show yeah all real all real and the
action is real too if I've had enough
Jack honest but do you do know soccer or
is that part of the the fun of this that
I think you're a football coach going
are you like a real football coach like
arm football then you go over there okay
exactly like though the whole premise
yeah I was a I'm a football coach from
Wichita State which does not a football
team so and then yeah I had a viral
video kind of like you know that great
video of Roy Williams with you know
walking into the locker
after a target victory and dance and
then everything for his players and that
video gets to the eye of the owner of a
professional soccer team over there in
in the UK and so they hire me you know
just to sort of shake things up because
they're at the point of possibly being
relegated and all that and so yeah I
hadn't but to answer your question I've
learned I learned more and more with
every with every night that I uh you
know play fifa you know I mean yes lots
I learn a little bit more about the
beautiful game but in all honestly no I
didn't I don't know much and a lot of
those commercials like the guy who plays
my assistant coach Brendon the hunt
who's also plays my assistant coach on
the show in one day co-writers
co-creators that's how we describe he
describes you know football or soccer to
me is by using metaphor whether it be
from you know 90s NBA 80s hip-hop
Broadway musicals like you can break it
down for me if I am you know paralleling
because something I already know and
that's sort of part of the fun of you
know at least for the the drive for the
comedy of the show and then the rest is
all just you know the high stakes are
you too old now I think you're turning
went 45 so are you too old to play video
games at home will well your wife allow
you to play video again oh yeah yeah no
we got a little six-year-old boy who we
play we will play through you know Lego
Star Wars I mean there's a deep deep
concern in our household about him
becoming addicted but i but i we have we
have a group of guys from from the show
that do play fifa like they have a thing
called pro clubs you know that we play
almost you know almost nightly you know
like a golf course like hey you know we
have a text chain going hey you know
someone sends out the bat signal then we
hop on there for you know a game a game
takes 17 minutes we have that down
because all of us have partners and you
know other responsibilities so you can
only sit in a room with a control in
your hair is so long and sounds like a
series in itself Jason I mean with this
you know with this twitch platform
anything's possible
you know the core you know quarantine
and the internet anything to show Paul
is Will Ferrell
not this time oh he's not okay I'm not
gonna take it personal if you don't
were you gonna were you upset in the
slightest when Will Ferrel interrupted
your phone call no okay no you know
honestly I feel like it's you know he's
got to do it there's demons there but
you know I bet there's part of him that
was upset that he did it you know I've
never really got into it I think this
part of him you know probably felt you
know like I let I let people down like
it's too needy too thirsty as the kids
say you know but no it didn't didn't
bother me at all oh god we laughed so
hard it was four years ago and but you
know that that it's those moments that
remind you of who who how funny people
are your line was so quick and so sharp
is like you know you could have won no I
didn't I need an email you could have
emailed it was just so in the moment and
it was such a throwaway line but I still
remember it because you're right
and will of course played it off and I
think it was he acted like you you
weren't on the phone and he just had to
call in I think we were planning a trip
to Dublin and he wanted to go to the
Guinness brewery it was just so random
and he's like damn yeah and I'm doing an
interview with Jason okay hey I really
want to go to Dublin with you guys and
then that's when I think he said can you
emailed you know ya know maybe maybe it
was in the car maybe was doing the same
things or knows but but ya know I mean
that will Tom Hanks Oprah Winfrey
Beyonce there's certain people that say
in a ref you don't mind I mean maybe
after maybe if it becomes a visual
that's like you know again if he would
have done it today then that'd be
something we'd have to have offline
conversations about you know well good
luck with all the projects certainly
with what's going on with tournament of
laughs it's great talk to you thanks
again we press talked in four years all
right Thank You Jay that's jason
sudeikis tournament of laughs and it's
Sundays at 10:00 Eastern on TBS